I basically, in general, responded to the
building as a whole, particularly the exterior
of the building, confronting the orange-ness
of the brick, and the horizontality of the
pattern in the exterior of the building. The
amphitheater, as well, thatÕs a particular
structure that I included in my design. Up
here, in fact, the way that I have the pattern
end, open, end and begin again in that particular
spot.
I do the drawings by hand. I like that directness.
I like that approach. It becomes a kind of
painterly exercise, in a way, just going through
this tactile, tangible process of mapping
the design on the wall.
I love the power of design, pattern, and symbol
in traditional African art, and I learn from
it quite a lotÑthe sense of invention, drawing,
the sense of space, material.
You can do so many things with color and create
so many different situations, and I wanted
to create ultimately a positive situation
here with the colors. I didnÕt want to have
colors that could be ultimately cloudy or
depressive. I wanted thought provoking colors,
interesting colors, interesting and dynamic
situations, environmental situations. When
I make these kinds of installations, it seems
often enough that I deal with each wall as
a separate event, and a circumstance or situation
based on how it exists, and then how it exists
with the space adjacent to it. The first wall
was sort of like just the beginning of, letÕs
say, a concert, where you have the big, loud
drums and the instruments tuning, and all
thatÕs just [claps], just this CHH CHH CHH,
just this beginning. I call it Wall One, which
is the entry wall at the door, and Wall Two,
which is the wall adjacent to itÉhow they
meet at the corner and they fan out in this
kind of diagonal explosion. They just explode
outward.
I was thinking also of people traveling through
the spaceÑof the particular type of person
traveling through the space: the students.
And what are they going to be doing here?
TheyÕre going to be studying, theyÕre going
to be communicating, having a community here,
living here. So I was thinking about that
sort of environment, too. What kind of color,
coloration, design would be conducive to that
kind of activity. Work that is in public space,
like thisÉI think people are able to come
to it and to painting in a much more open,
generous, and quicker way. ItÕs immediate.
ItÕs the body feels the painting.